I should write a book, dude.
Um, anyway, ah.
Was a little bit sick because I was doing my shows and traveling all over
creation.
Dude. You know what happens? You know what happens too much, man. Look,
here's the deal, man. Either make it so I can watch movies.
No. Okay. So if I'm on a plane, make it.
So there's two options you got here,
planes don't.
Turn on the back of the TV head rest until after the plane takes
off.
Or make.
It so I can watch movies. Right? When I sit down,
when I board the plane and shut the.
Up over the PA. Okay. There's.
The amount of things that flight attendants say when you
board the plane is absolutely asinine.
Is it all good? Now, dude, you sit down. Well,
we have to, Hey guys, if we can do a crunch back for four where you know,
you got to put it back forward because you know, if you don't do, you know,
you've got to make sure it goes in it on the top of the thing.
If you don't get it to her yet, this is for the first day.
And then what we do is you,
you gotta sit down in the thing and move all the way to,
unfortunately it's a full flat, all right, dude.
I'm trying to watch Spider-Man farm from home, dude. Do you,
do you understand me? Okay. So the vine, so then say all the.
Well, you can get rewards code, you get rewards, Platypus wards codes.
You can get rewards.
If you just sign up for the rewards codes and then wifi fly Phi PI Phi,
and then awards codes, and then make-up or Decker,
flag chime and put your seat pack and a flag champ. All right, fine.
I'm trying to watch Spider-Man far from home.
So then make it,
so you say all this and then the flight takes off and
then I could turn on.
Pokemon.
Dude. The only time like it, you can tell I'm on a flight.
If I'm watching Pokemon, I turned on Pokemon, dude.
It's so weird.
How like flights we'll have like the movies that you can choose and there'll be
like a bunch of new releases.
And then all of a sudden it'll be like a rear window.
Why the would you have rear window on.
Jet blue? Well, what.
Kind of cinephile is going to be like, oh yeah, it's in my,
if who the is going to watch rear window. Oh yeah.
So it's been a while since I've seen that Hitchcock movie,
I'd love to see it in a four inch screen. Dude.
The only person who's watching rear window, first of all,
is watching it in theater or at home.
Nobody would ever watch a movie that a cinephile would watch in a
on the back of the headrest. Oh cool. Are they got eat too?
Mama. Tom Yan. Oh,
watch it in the back of someone's head. Oh dude,
what the.
They've got? What's that movie that they would have.
Oh, they've got a, oh dude. They've got a Fellini collection. Oh,
well let me watch it on the back of someone's head.
Oh, they've gotten the Dolce Vita or whatever the it's called. Oh dude,
let me watch it on the back.
Of Rick's head.
Yeah. Let me watch a what's that one? That he, oh,
Lolita. Oh, Lolita.
Let me watch it while I'm eating cashews, dude like this, ah.
This is the part where he tries to the 14 year old.
And shut the up while I'm trying to watch it, do it. And if you want to have,
and we're just here to, and we're welcoming you and you're welcome. Welcome.
We just want to welcome you while you walk into the thing and remember you can
choose to fly wherever you want to choose to this effect that you chose.
I chose you.
Why are you doing another commercial on the when I'm already riding the
commercial? It's so annoying, dude. [inaudible]
dude, I'm trying to watch Aqua man
chill, man. And then the hallways, the hunky Dory,
put your seatbelts on video comes on in the middle of, you know, you're getting,
you're just starting to get into the drop or whatever.
You're watching the drop with, uh, Tom Hardy and James Gandolfini.
And then all of a sudden it's like,
hi, we know here at American airlines, you can choose any flight.
So what we want to do is make sure you're the most safety Falcons.
Cause that's the safety first.
Well it's anything. Now we've got, uh,
we've got an ambiguous and then draws you to this person,
buckling up their seatbelts and he's light skinned.
You don't know what race he is. Whoops. You forgot something.
Here's somebody, here's a lady with a short haircut,
handing him a pamphlet on how to do it.
Hey look, we made it funky. There's twins and they sit next to each other,
but they're like one one's eating pretzels. And one's drinking
here at American airlines. We know no matter what your race, gender,
or how tall you are, you can do whatever you want. But we're thankful that you,
if they played us and here,
we got a bunch of different Asian people doing a dance.
Now take your seat. There's a life Fest and there's life. That's another thing.
Make sure to always, even though you already know this,
make sure to put it on someone else before.
Make sure you put it on yourself before you put it on and you put it on yourself
first because if you don't and then you die, then the other person dies. Anyway.
That's what we're secretly saying. Even though we don't say
a light-skinned guy woopsy
anyway, enjoy, enjoy Spider-Man far from home
fighting. We're shedding.
Here's the men in black guys dancing around with some life vests.
So annoying dude. Just Lem watch Aqua man.
Oh dude. It's so pretentious that they have LA Dolce Vita in the thing, dude,
in the movie catalog, you know, it's like, well you never.
Know, you know, maybe was the people want to watch the deer hunter.
You never know the people that jet blue. You never know, dude. You never know.
We may want to have one too.
Um, so yeah, so that's all I'm saying. So I flew.